donald trump has finally broken his
silence on the fbi raid of his
mar-a-lago home and he instantly
imploded on his very now extraordinarily
famous platform truth social you know
truth social it's an exciting place
truth essential yeah um so the big news
of course over the last 48 hours that
the fbi executed a search warrant at
donald trump's home in florida they were
in his safe they were in his office they
were presumably in his residence we
don't yet know the full scope of the
search warrant or what they took or what
they were seeking but donald trump
breaking his silence on tuesday with one
post on truth social and then spent most
of this morning posting about it
completely embarrassing post starting
yesterday with quote
a horrible thing that took place
yesterday at mar-a-lago we are no better
than a third world country a banana
republic
people not being above the law is not
exactly
third world stuff
it is a continuation of russia russia
russia impeachment hoax 1 impeachment
hoax 2 the no collusion molar report and
more well that's not true this has
nothing to do with that this has to do
with trump at the end of his presidency
taking documents it has nothing to do
with those other things and then trump
goes on to say to make matters worse it
is all in my opinion a coordinated
attack with radical left democrat state
and local district attorneys and
attorneys general there is no evidence
whatsoever of that and in fact the
report is that biden did not even know
in advance about this then trump
continuing on truth social quote biden
knew all about this
just like he knew about all of hunter's
deals
it does not appear that that is true a
report from politico is that indeed the
biden administration had no advance
notice about the mar-a-lago search could
they be lying sure anyone could be lying
at any time but at this point there is
no evidence that biden even knew ahead
of time about this trump continuing what
took place yesterday and long before was
an unprecedented infringement of the
rights of every american citizen no it
wasn't they had a search warrant they
had a judge sign it the fbi director
presumably knew about it the attorney
general presumably knew about it and
everybody was involved presumably
dotting tease and crossing eyes as who
was it that said the other day i think
it was hannity that said something about
dotting t's and crossing eyes
trump going on scam after scam year
after year it is all the radical
democrats really know it is their
lifeblood they have no shame and our
country is paying a very big price
accountability is a good thing not a bad
thing trump continuing his tirade quote
the fbi and others from the federal
government would not let anyone
including my lawyers be anywhere near
the areas that were rummaged and
otherwise looked at during the raid on
mar-a-lago everyone was asked to leave
the premises they wanted to be left
alone without witnesses taking or
hopefully not planting
planting there now this is the new thing
planting evidence we'll get to that why
did they strongly insist on having
nobody watching them everybody out obama
and clinton were never raided despite
big disputes
what on earth would you have raided
barack obama for i mean it just quite
frankly makes no sense whatsoever
so donald trump
exploding on truth essential
and making a dozen or more
unfounded assertions this thing about
nobody was allowed there
look at the commentary from former fbi
agents about what is and is not allowed
during the execution of such search
warrants and you will find that at this
time there's no evidence anything wrong
was done i've seen several people in my
life try to quit smoking or vaping and
quitting has so many benefits but it
does require a strategy and our sponsor
fume is a one of a kind inhaler that can
help you quit smoking as a replacement
for the hand-to-mouth habit of smoking
there is no smoke there is no vapor and
there's no nicotine fume is just a small
inhaler
handcrafted from wood it uses cores
infused with fresh aromatic plant oils
for you to taste and enjoy
instead of a nasty cigarette or a vape
you can use fume while flying which is a
big plus because there's no smoke no
vapor no nicotine fume has flavors like
peppermint and conker with a powerful
minty sensation to simulate the menthol
cigarettes they have other flavors like
cozy chai i love chai myself and lemon
berry bliss for a sweeter experience
fume has helped thousands of people quit
people who have tried everything else
read the reviews we talked to the fume
team they're very proud of the lives
that they've impacted throw out the
cigarettes get rid of the vapes head
over to breathe fume dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman to get 10
off your entire order the link is down
below